more public charter school students  headed back to in-person classes today  the coral academy of science campuses  expanding their hybrid learning  the campus on nellis air force base will  now have k through third grade  on campus students will either be in a  morning class or afternoon class  five days a week it will be capped at  forty percent enrollment  at campus at any given day we wanna  bring back  students uh we're actively doing that  and we're doing it in phases  uh but in terms of doing that we just  have to make sure we do it safely  students of course will wear masks and  social distance they'll eat lunch off  campus  and a crew will sanitize the classrooms  between shifts and of students